support move University in the
production of more video tutorials by
making a financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
on move University calm the link will be
in the description below thank you and
enjoy alright so we're gonna continue
our discussion of significant figures
and discuss the rounding rules as well
as exact numbers and sort of what's
going on with those things so one
question is that what happens with sig
figs when it comes to calculations and
rounding calculations you'll have
multiple numbers maybe these numbers
have different numbers of significant
figures what happens well the
measurements and the values that have
the lowest certainty the lowest
certainty they limit the number of
significant digits so basically your
answer can only be a certain as your
least certain measurement ok so let's
think about an example let's say you're
in a lab and you need to find the
density of a certain block of some
unknown metal what do you need if you
want to find the density all you need is
the the mass and the volume because
density as we mentioned before equals
mass divided by volume so we need to
find both of these values so you can
find the mass by using a balance right
and let's say that the metal you find it
to be 25.0 60 grams so you have an m
equal to 25 point 0 60 grams and then
you use you find the volume by measuring
the amount of displaced fluid in a
graduated cylinder so you measure the
volume of just the fluid and then you
throw the block in there and then you
take the new measurement of the volume
and then you subtract the two to find
the volume that the block displaced so
let's say you do that and you find the
volume according to your graduated
cylinder to be equal to let's say three
point five milliliters three point five
milliliters okay and then you want to go
ahead and find the density because you
have both of these values so the density
will equal the mass of the volume so 25
points 0 60 grams G is ugly let's try
that again G ok / 3.5 milliliters if you
do this if you put this into your
calculator you'll get seven point one
six grams per milliliter now you'll
notice though that this number has five
significant figures this one only has
two so you're limited in your certainty
by the one that has less significant
figures which is this one so your answer
can only have that many so here 7.16 we
need to round that off to 7.2 grams per
milliliter and that's the density that
we have and then you can predict based
on this density what that unknown metal
might be okay so let's look at the
actual rules in more detail so there are
rules as far as arithmetic goes in fact
we just did the example of
multiplication division when it comes to
multiplying and dividing numbers with
different significant figures the answer
must have the same number of sig figs as
the measurement with the fewest sig figs
so in the case before we had 11
measurement with 5 sig figs and one with
two we had to give the answer with two
significant figures here we have three
different values this one has three
significant figures this one has four
significant figures this one has to so
our answer can't have more than two if
you plug this into your calculator 5.45
times six point four three two times 24
meters all these are meters we're trying
to find a volume here you get 840 1.30 5
6 meters cubed that's a lot of sig figs
we can't keep all of those right how
many is that exactly that's three plus
four that's seven significant figures we
can't have that we have to have an
answer with two with two significant
figures because we're limited by this
one so our answer has to be eight
hundred forty meters cubed that only has
two significant figures that's for
multiplication and division
but what happens when you have addition
and subtraction in that case your answer
must have the same number of decimal
places as the measurement with the
fewest two decimal places so it's not
it's not sig figs per se this time it's
about decimal places so if you have
forty two point six milliliters and 18
point 18 milliliters and you want to add
these two you've got three sig figs here
and for hear your answer is not going to
be dependent on that it's not they're
going to be dependent on the number of
sig figs it's going to be dependent on
the number of decimal places so this one
has one decimal place right and this one
has to so your answer has to have just
one decimal place so if you actually
punch that in you get 60 point seven
eight right which has two decimal places
you have to round that off to 60 point
eight milliliters now on both of these
cases I round it off the answers so
basically i removed I removed a digit to
keep the correct number of sig figs ok
how do I know exactly what to do there
well there are the rounding rules ok so
what you do is that if the digit that
your room first rule is that if the
digit you're removing is greater than 5
what you do is you take the preceding
number and you increase that number by 1
so let's say rounding 60 point seven
eight milliliters the we're trying we're
going from these for sig figs we want
only to have we want to i only have
three sig figs right we want to remove
this last digit here so we want to value
with only three sig figs well this is
another digit that we're going to remove
the eight right if this number is
greater than five right so what we're
gonna do is we're going to take this
previous number the preceding number and
increasing by 1 to get 60.8 milliliters
ok
what if that digit is less than five so
in this case we've got 82 points before
the four is less than five so if the
three what are we can do with that in
this case the preceding number stays the
same so we're going to remove this for
and then because it's less than five day
22.3 is not rounded updated 2.4 it's
going to stay a 22.3 now what if the de
jure removed equals five and assuming
that that five is followed only by zeros
I'm gonna gonna highlight that only by
zeros okay what do you do then what you
do is you round to either make or keep
the preceding number an even number so
what does that mean it's kind of
confusing okay so if we have three point
seven 50 what we do let's say we want to
remove we're going to remove the the
five here okay this number equals five
it's followed by a zero and only by
zeros what we're going to do is we're
going to remove this and we have to
round the preceding number which is the
seven to make sure that it's even well
seven is odd right so if this number is
odd we're going to we're going to round
up to make it three point eight which is
going to be an even number okay that's
because seven was an odd number so you
it's increase if the its increased by
one if the preceding number is odd ok
but if if the preceding number if the
preceding number is an even number it
remains the same so 3.6 a 3.65 would be
routed just a 3.6 and the reason why
here is that so that we're not rounding
up every single time and writing up more
often that we remain the same so this is
to make sure that when we round we're
not over rounding up now one thing that
I must say is that if the five being
removed
if the five being removed is followed by
nonzero digits then you just round up
and that's often the case okay so if
this was a 3.50 one or 3.5 08 the fact
that it's not followed by zeros mean
that you would have to round that seven
up likewise here the six would be
rounded up okay so that would just be
according to rule one now I will be
completely Frank here with this rule
number three most of the time I
personally ignore it and that's because
most of the time it doesn't really
matter now that that might like upset
some people but when it comes to being
practical like when it comes to like
doing problems in your homework or on
exams more honestly even in lab
sometimes like small rounding like like
this isn't the biggest deal in fact only
the only time i ever have actually seen
this particular rule you know be
relevant is when the question is
specifically asking to make sure that
you know this rule that might sound kind
of crazy but hopefully that made sense
yeah most of the time just these first
two rules are enough and this actually
this last rule number four is really
really important I highly value this one
this one says that when you're
performing a multi-step calculation do
not round your answer until you get to
the final answer I do not round any of
your numbers until you get the final
answer this is really really important
when you have a ton of different numbers
you're multiplying dividing adding this
adding that you know all these different
things most of the time it's multiplying
and dividing you're gonna get numbers
with crazy amounts of sig figs and
you'll be tempted to round don't round
it's it's in your best interest not to
and I say that because that's going to
make the answer closer to the answer
that it should be now of course you can
round a little bit but if your answer
requires like you know three sig figs or
for sig figs you want to keep maybe like
six or seven I don't know it there's no
like exact number you should keep but I
would personally keep as many as
possible so as to make sure that the
answer is as close to correct as
possible I normally just do it all on my
calculator so that I don't have to worry
about rounding off at all but this is
this is rule that I really like and
really really good to me all right next
up exact numbers what are exact numbers
exact numbers are numbers that have no
uncertainty at all they have no
uncertainty okay they have an infinite
number of significant figures okay so
what does that mean well let's let's
talk about some examples these really
come in the idea of exact numbers are
really important when it comes to
conversion factors for instance the
conversion factor equations listed here
one dozen eggs is 12 eggs one dozen is
defined as 12 of something so you might
look at this and say well one that's one
significant figure 12 that's two
significant figures so if i had this
conversion factor you know as 12 12 or
12 24 or 12 to one that would be i could
my answer can only have one sig fig and
that's not the case and the reason why
is because these numbers are exact
numbers one doesn't is the exactly 12 of
things so i could rewrite this as one
point zero zero zero zero zero and go on
forever right that that many dozen is 12
point 0 000000 all the way till forever
right because these values are exactly
you know 1 in 12 right you guys many
zeros as you like it again they have an
infinite number of significant figures
right same thing here with one kilogram
of 1,000 grams 1,000 grams is exactly
one kilogram one kilogram is exactly
1,000 grams so you're not limited in
your number significant figures you can
put a point zero and a point zero you
know go on adding zeros forever to the
end of these numbers and that that's why
they'd have an infinite number of
significant figures there there is no
uncertainty at all these numbers are
exact and one inch is 2.54 centimeters
exactly so this is
really important conversion factor when
it comes to you know switching from the
English standard to the to the metric
system super super important this is an
exact number this is not limit your your
number of significant figures at all in
fact that's actually what this last
sentence down here is trying to say is
that exact numbers
do not limit the number of significant
figures in an answer from a calculated
using them so if you have a calculation
using a conversion factor that appears
to have only one two or maybe three
significant figures that's not the case
if there are exact numbers exact numbers
have an infinite number of significant
figures and therefore do not limit the
number of significant figures in your
answer so I hope that video is helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful be sure to video with the
like and don't forget to subscribe if
you haven't already also be sure to
share the video with anyone you think
might find it helpful thanks and happy
studying